[Musique]
l'api nous pompons winnie le doudou et
le combat n'en des enfants alors si par
malheur il vient à disparaître
catastrophe pour éviter le drame julie
colo a créé daudou malin un site
internet de vente de doudou avec 7500
références différentes
en fait c est une de mes nièces qu'avait
son doudou qui était absolument
pitoyable dans un état plus que foutu et
en fait je voulais lui faire la surprise
de lui remplacé donc j'ai fait toutes
les boutiques tous les magasins du coin
et je n'ai rien trouvé
sauf sur internet à 50 euros quoi le
doudou alors du coup comme je faisais
beaucoup les brocantes et les vide
greniers
j'ai commencé à en collecter quelques
uns et puis petit à petit le stock a
grossi et doudou malin est arrivé en
elle charge une société spécialisée de
lui créer son site
mais pour le reste elle s'occupe de tout
sous le regard de ses compagnons elle
prépare l'expédition des derniers adopté
ils sont parfois en route pour l'autre
côté du globe
hier j'en voyais pour l'australie là
aujourd'hui a un paquet pour la belgique
un autre pour les pays bas
quant aux nouveaux arrivants qui
viennent de rejoindre le stock
il passe d'abord sous le feu des
projecteurs avec entre 700 et 1000
ventes par mois doudou malin pour
ambition de devenir le site numéro un du
doudou perdu et pour ceux dont le doudou
est rare on a pensé à tout donc on a une
alerte email vous pouvez vous inscrire
et en fait des cons en rentrant vous
avez une alerte ambitieux et motivés
avec son site gilles colo a déjà
remporté le prix 100 jours pour
entreprendre en 2015